it sounds like you might want to shoot
those hidden blades for the remainder of
the year because it sounds like we may
not be getting a big new assassin's
creed game in 2016 a new report suggests
that Ubisoft will skip 2016 in favor of
a 2017 release for a new game set in
Egypt news of this first cropped up on
4chan via neogaf where an alleged
developer claimed that the new game
would be a complete revamp of the series
featuring a Witcher feel with player
progression in a free-form combat system
kotaku has since corroborated some of
these details saying that the game is
currently called Assassin's Creed Empire
and could signal a bi-annual release
schedule for the series moving forward
it also says that the whole and
ubisoft's ball schedule could be filled
by watchdogs to which is reportedly set
in San Francisco according to the for
champosta new protagonist will be a
slave or former slave with a pet eagle
that the player will be able to control
this new assassin's creed game is
expected to be a lot more colorful and
have a lot more story we reached out to
be soft and as you'd expect they told us
we can't comment on rumor or speculation
if you're a fan of the series you're not
we will still see plenty of Assassin's
Creed in 2016 next week sees the release
of assassin's creed chronicles India and
in February players will be able to get
their hands on assassin's creed
chronicles Russia and of course Michael
Fassbender will down the iconic assassin
robes this December for the blockbuster
film do you think I'd buy a new release
schedule is a good idea for the
franchise for more on Assassin's Creed
you're already in the right place
you